[Música]
miles de aficionados asisten a las
honras fúnebres de Pelé que iniciaron
hoy en Brasil su ataúd estará hasta el
martes en el estadio del Santos el club
que lo descubrió y en el que jugó la
mayor parte de su vida
en el Vaticano Hoy es el primer día de
Capilla ardiente del papa emérito de
Benedicto 16 con miles de feligreses
acudiendo a la Basílica de San Pedro el
funeral será el 5 de enero
al menos 63 soldados rusos murieron
endoniets que por un ataque de Ucrania
la cifra la da el Ministerio de defensa
de Rusia que agrega que el bombardeo fue
con misiles de alta precisión quien
afirma que los fallecidos son cerca de
Bienvenido a un nuevo resumen
Informativo en francés 24 los acompaña
Daniela Blandón vamos a comenzar en
Brasil este lunes el estadio del Santos
recibió a su mayor estrella los restos
del futbolista Pelé estarán allí hasta
el martes para que sus seguidores puedan
darle el último adiós al evento
asistieron importantes figuras como el
presidente de la FIFA ya ni infantino y
también políticos brasileños Alba
Santana tiene los detalles
solo a 2 de enero ya fue uno de los
autos más esperados del año el de los
restos de Pelé la leyenda brasileña del
fútbol que pasará 24 horas en el estadio
de fútbol de Santos para que sus
seguidores le puedan dar el último adiós
es un sentimiento de pérdida de un ídolo
para todos es un ídolo además de una
persona que elevó el nombre de Brasil en
todos los rincones
pero se va con una misión cumplida es un
ídolo nacional y mundial
las primeras horas del velatorio del
Astro además de miles de fans acudieron
figuras importantes desde varios
miembros de la Corte Suprema del país
que también quisieron despedirse hasta
el presidente de la FIFA ya ni infantino
que acompañó a los familiares de la
Estrella en el Duelo y pidió que todos
los países le rindieran un pequeño
homenaje vamos a
a pedir a todas las federaciones en el
mundo entero 211 países
que nombran un estadio en cada país del
mundo con el nombre con el nombre de
pelé porque creo que los jóvenes en el
mundo entero las futuras generaciones
tienen que saber
Y recordarse de quién era Pelé el
conocido como rey del fútbol que murió a
los 82 años a causa de un cáncer será
enterrado el martes en una ceremonia más
íntima pelea marcó la vida de miles de
Amantes del fútbol en Brasil y en todo
el mundo y siempre será recordado por su
yogo bonito
ahora vamos a estar Vaticano porque la
capilla ardiente del Papa emérito
Benedicto 16 inició este lunes y se
extenderá hasta el miércoles para que
los feligreses puedan despedirse a la
ceremonia asistieron hoy el presidente y
la primera ministra de Italia mientras
se aguarda por la asistencia de la
delegación de Alemania el jueves será el
funeral que será celebrado por el propio
Papa Francisco Ramiro tiene los detalles
comenzó la diosa Benedicto 16 el cuerpo
del Papa emérito fue trasladado hasta la
Basílica de San Pedro en las primeras
horas del lunes donde permanecerá hasta
el miércoles para que miles de fieles
puedan presentarles sus respetos y
despedirse
[Música]
Esta es una que tienes una experiencia
más personal vinimos a decir gracias a
preguntar algo Tienes la sensación de
estar frente a alguien que llegó al otro
lado ha sido una oración hermosa
a nivel diplomático las únicas
autoridades invitadas Serán las de
Italia y Alemania informó El Vaticano
resaltó la presencia de la primera
ministra Georgia Melanie y el presidente
Sergio matarela Mientras que el jefe de
la conferencia episcopal alemana abrió
un libro de condolencias para Benedicto
estoy impresionado y personalmente muy
conmovido por la gran participación
sobre la muerte del Papa emérito
Benedicto XVI muchas personas han tomado
parte en esto están yendo las iglesias
participando en oraciones encendiendo
velas y escribiendo en los libros de
condolencias
la muerte de Benedicto a sus 95 años
dejó al Vaticano en una situación
inédita en más de seis siglos no existen
estatutos para el fallecimiento de un
Papa emérito Lo cierto es que su
entierro se llevará a cabo el 5 de enero
en la plaza de San Pedro y la misa La
celebrará el Papa Francisco siguiendo
sus propios deseos el cuerpo de
Benedicto 16 descansarán las criptas
bajo la basílica en el mismo lugar donde
fue enterrado el papa Juan Pablo II en
el año 2005
y en noticias de la guerra el ataque
aéreo de Rusia contra Ucrania continuó
por tercera noche consecutiva dejando
sin electricidad y calefacción a los
alrededores de la capital kiev y
causando también varios heridos Mientras
tanto Ucrania se adjudicó al ataque que
causó la muerte de decenas de soldados
rusos en el este del país en la
provincia de donniae ocupada por Moscú
Rusia confirmó la muerte de 63 de sus
efectivos veamos el informe
en un suburbio al noreste de kiev sergi
está limpiando los daños después de que
un dron Ruso cayera en las calles esta
madrugada
por la noche un golpe muy duro incluso
los muebles se movieron
como ya había alerta aérea entendimos
que hubo una explosión
salía el balcón y vi cristales rotos
drones misiles y proyectiles cayeron en
toda Ucrania durante la noche las
autoridades ucranianas dijeron que 40
drones que se dirigían a kiev fueron
interceptados Aunque algunas
instalaciones energéticas resultaron
dañadas causando cortes desde octubre
los ataques rusos contra los suministros
de Electricidad y agua han sido casi
semanales mientras sus fuerzas
terrestres luchan por avanzar pero esta
tercera noche consecutiva de bombardeos
no tiene precedentes Ucrania ha
contratado con dureza y su ejército
Afirma haber matado a unos 400 soldados
rusos y herido a otros 300 en un ataque
contra un dormitorio militar y un
almacén de municiones en la ciudad de
maquisca en el este de Ucrania ocupado
por Rusia cifras exageradas según
oficiales rusos los sistemas de defensa
aérea rusos derribaron dos cohetes como
resultado del ataque de cuatro misiles
con una ojiva altamente explosiva en un
punto despliegue temporal 63 militares
rusos murieron Ucrania también ha estado
llevando a cabo sus propios ataques con
drones el último alcanzó una instalación
energética en la región de brillansk
cerca de la frontera ucraniana
y en noticias económicas de la jornada
la recesión podría llegar a un tercio de
la economía mundial en 2023 esto según
el fondo monetario internacional
en declaraciones a la cadena
estadounidense CVS la jefa del organismo
cristalina georgeba aseguró que para la
mayoría de países este año será incluso
más difícil que 2022 económicamente
hablando e incluyendo al menos a la
mitad de Europa sin embargo espera que
la mayor Economía del mundo Estados
Unidos esquive esta recesión gracias a
la fortaleza de su mercado laboral
entre tanto dos palestinos murieron en
enfrentamientos con el ejército israelí
en lasis Jordania ocupada uno de ellos
pertenecía a un grupo armado los choques
comenzaron después de que Israel
bombardeara y destruyera las casas de
otros dos palestinos a quienes les
dispararon en septiembre del año pasado
tras presuntamente matar a un comandante
israelí Samuel Salgado nos cuenta más
miles de palestinos se congregaron para
lamentar la muerte de dos jóvenes cerca
de la ciudad de yin en el norte de las
discordania ocupada
samer juchilley Fueron impactados por
disparos del ejército israelí en medio
de un violento enfrentamiento con la
población local que protestaba por la
demolición de las casas de dos
palestinos acusados de matar a un
soldado israelí en septiembre del año
pasado
los propietarios de las casas demolidas
recuerdan a las víctimas como Héroes de
la resistencia Palestina estos casos
Ahora son solo un montón de piedras un
símbolo de la fuerza de nuestros hijos y
su fuerza de asalto y la fuerza de su
determinación
la política que implementa la ocupación
no traerán resultado definitivamente no
el resultado que esperan no quebrarán
nuestro espíritu y no nos van a quebrar
al contrario eso hará que la gente sea
más decidida y firme
[Música]
el Ministerio de salud de Palestina
confirmó que una de las víctimas
pertenecía a las brigadas de los
mártires de alaxa facción armada del
Movimiento Político fata que gobierna en
si Jordania y considerada como
organización terrorista por Israel sin
embargo la organización yihadista jamás
activan la franja de gaza aseguró que
uno de los jóvenes muertos pertenecía al
grupo desde la primavera pasada el
ejército israelí ha estado realizando
incursiones en territorio palestino casi
a diario incursiones que terminan en
violencia y disturbios tan solo el año
pasado 150 palestinos murieron en el
contexto de las redadas israelíes
convirtiéndose el 2022 en el año más
violento en cisjordania desde 2006
tras el reciente regreso al poder de
bellamine taniagua en Israel las
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos temen
una escalada de la violencia
netanyahu conformó Un gobierno
ultranacionalista asociado con el
sionismo y ha expresado públicamente que
desea expandi los asentamientos
israelíes en cisjordania
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo los invitamos a que sigan
con nosotros
[Música]